meagan Markel the Duchess is under fire
again this time for speaking out about
the black lives matter movement I know
you know the black lives matter I think
Megan anticipated a degree of backlash
speaking out about the black lives
matter campaign because there's always a
backlash whenever she speaks about
anything you will always get the haters
on social media Megan knows that and how
he knows that they just tend to ignore
it I wanted to say the right thing and I
was really nervous that I I wouldn't or
that it would get picked apart this is
six minutes of carefully considered
speech the only wrong thing to say is to
say nothing with comments like quote now
there's a life that doesn't matter the
question is has Megan been targeted
especially by the British press because
of her race some of the slurs that I've
heard the really offensive jokes or the
names it's just hit me in a really
strong way they have accusations have
been racist overtones to some of the
coverage in the British tabloid press
and and you know Harry has said as much
as you think that's that statement he
released a couple of months after it was
announced that they were dating he
complained about the racist and the
sexist and tones of some of the coverage
the phrase exotic DNA is one that comes
to mind that you know apparently the
couple we had an issue with the British
tabloids have also frequently pitted
Megan versus Kate just check out the
headlines to praise Kate but tear Megan
down for doing the exact same thing from
how they held their baby bumps to the
flowers in their bridal bouquets and
even avocados she will air enough to
show the dress can be criticized for it
Kate will wearing off the shoulder dress
and be praised for it does seem to be a
case of double standards towards the two
different duchesses no doubt Megan is
shielding one-year-old Archie from all
the hate and the couple is also
spreading the love calling Harry's
grandpa Prince Phillip on his nine
ninth birthday et has also learned that
Megan and Harry are reaching out to the
leaders of the black lives matter
movement to see how they can lend their
voices to the cause I'm told this is
something they want to keep private at
the moment while they work out what they
can do and how they can help they come
in on this from different perspectives
Megan as a Californian Kari is it as an
English man and that this is a campaign
that matters to them
[Music]